vertrauen vertrauen ist wichtig
gerade wenn es um berufsfelder
beispielsweise polizist anwalt
oder auch arzt geht
professor doktor mediziner laser luca
mit vertrauen extrem groß geschrieben
herzlich willkommen in meiner praxis
herzlich willkommen hier in meinem
krankenhaus meine lieben freunde hier
kann man seine gattin hinhängen
[Musik]
don't touch genau wir bewegen uns hier
einfach mal ein bisschen ich kann glaube
ich auch schneller laufen wenn die mich
einfach dass sie vorne ist meine tasche
die muss ich natürlich mitnehmen in den
op wir gehen los
[Musik]
professor dr mediziner laser luca wir
können natürlich hier ganz wie sie
durchgehend das hier ist der vorder raum
jetzt es mir auch wichtig dass hier
ordnung herrscht hier müssen wir dann
durch denn die anlockten shipping er bei
waren nur ein paar urin döschen ist in
hände wärmen also hier vorne müssen wir
jetzt glaube ich irgendwie rein das ist
völlig normal bei mir im krankenhaus
kann sie wieder aufrichten
professor doktor mediziner laser luca
kein problem so genau so läuft immer zu
arbeiten kein problem für die op
brauchen wir fast getroffen weil wir ein
bisschen auf ihr jetzt geht da rein
kommt so ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
ok
meister
warum hat der mülheimer plötzlich ein
eigenleben
[Musik]
ist das hier der horror spiel oder an
ärzte spiel
[Musik]
er schreibt mich doch nicht so ich will
mir sie durch lesen brauch die für
europa bei so einem kind ist wichtig
dass die mit
also wir haben die kleine ente hier und
laufen natürlich selbstverständlich
ich habe doch auch ein ausweis
ich holte neben erwartet 20 sekunden
später vertrauen wird hier groß
geschrieben
professor doktor mediziner laser luca 8
sind erst 23 meine unterschrift und
sogar code den können wir da jetzt auch
scannen geklappt
[Musik]
vielleicht mit mehr anlauf diese hand
tut mir so leid wir müssen halt irgendwo
ein personalausweis finden ich weiß
allerdings nicht wo der sein kann kann
man das hier aufziehen
ich räume auf so hier drin ist ja da
kann ich nichts mehr rausnehmen
ist ein guter alter schulfreund von mir
ich habe eine idee
dass man betrete aber die wussten also
hier sind auf jeden fall einige ausweise
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal einen mit
und kann damit jetzt hier damit nehme
ich jetzt die die ente oder meine tasche
mit ich muss als arzt eures vertrauens
natürlich prioritäten setzen und mich
natürlich verlassen entscheiden was
weniger ist wenn meine patienten und
auch für mich in der tasche habe ich
alle minute in syrien drin allem ein
werkzeug was ich im raum brauche von
daher beschäftigen wir uns jetzt mit dem
nächsten raum meine lieben freunde und
müssen hier aha da willkommen der ganze
sache schon näher so bitteschön dienten
beim start gelaufen meinte ich jetzt
auch fallen lassen
warum schwebe ich nicht weg wir haben
wir haben level 1 abgeschlossen
und damit will ich auch das heutige
video beenden in der nächsten episode
vom surgeons teenager wird euer
professor dr mediziner laser luca ein
wein transplantieren
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert main kanal klickt auf die
glocke zeigt das video und kommentiert
wer schon mal was gebrochen haben
görlitz ganges